hey guys welcome back to this demo rpg
series we're up to episode 19. so
without further ado let's dive right
into it so we're going to go into our
main and look for our fight sequence
here which is enter fight sequence and
we'll just check that out and we mainly
want to focus on this while loop here
so we now have well we got an action a
for attack we need to display some more
options here so let's check the
abilities we're really gonna have to
analyze and think about this
well first of all let's give the option
to do some inventory stuff i think well
we wanna you can you should be able to
like use potions in battle and stuff you
know so that's what i'm thinking here i
don't necessarily want you to be able to
change equipment but it doesn't matter
we could say you can swap equipment why
not so let's just have
an eye
inventory option and that way you'll be
able to go in there and use stuff now
maybe we'll say like we'll have this
special version of the inventory
that is for combat so we'll have like
void
combat
inventory
and it's going to be about the same as
the normal inventory except we're only
going to be able to allow to do one
thing so we'll just copy all that same
stuff paste it on down
into combat inventory and let's analyze
this real quick
so basically we want to
if you
press u and actually use something and
it's successful
in that case we actually want to exit
and be done basically and you'll be done
with your turn
uh and so we'll have a little
full action use
and we'll start this as false so if they
end up toggling this action used to true
yeah in that case we'll
we'll uh do some special thing and they
make them use their turn in combat
basically so i think we're going to have
more logic here so i'm just going to
expand out these brackets a little bit
and let's make this nice and
full screen so you can all see what's
going on i've always forgot to do this
in all previous episodes pretty much
okay so if they use a potion
now this returns a boolean and let's
just take a look at this use function
turns true if the potion was used okay
so
we can just go
action used here action
used equals
and same with equip let's check out
equip here returns a bull
turns true
okay turns
true if
whip was
successful
so we'll say like one swap of an item
will also count which doesn't make a
whole lot of sense how you gonna swap a
piece of armor really but eh whatever
it's a game
so we're just going to go action used
equals
and then at back at the top of our while
loop while not done
and well not
action used
alright so we need to also do one more
thing when we exit this function we need
to consider whether they use their
astronauts so let's actually return a
bull on this one um
so yeah let's just return action used
because uh we want to return true or
false that way we know if they used an
action or not okay that should do it
we now have a combat inventory and in
our fight sequence
let's just fix this up a little bit if
they press i
[Music]
well now we need to
reformulate this right here a little bit
where it was a while not a because now
they have more options so we'll just go
action equals get
air
i guess we do still need a while uh
let's go with action done
this round let's make a while so
it's gonna basically try to get your
whatever you're doing
until you actually do something and
let's just reset this boolean
every
every single round
started out as false of course there we
go
actually done this round while not
action done this round so when you
haven't done your action we're going to
do get care
and then we're going to switch on it so
we're actually going to need a switch
here
could do if else the switch is going to
be a little more efficient
and i'm just going to have our options
here case a
it's going to be a standard attack how
did we have it before hold on i need to
look at this
wait i'm doing it a terrible way
case a
attack right we'll just put this for a
second
case
i combat
inventory action
done this
round equals combat inventory because of
course this is going to return true if
they took their action in the
inventory and that's about it for now
we'll work on the abilities here in a
second but hey just getting your
inventory usable in combat is kind of
cool
okay so if we need to see the changes
for what uh how did we have our attack
before
we can just click on github stuff and
just take a look at it here
and main
and it'll show us the comparison of what
changed the diff if you will
and we can see previously we just had
action equals get care
uh yeah we didn't actually do anything
we just went down here and we did the
fight and there was the attack action so
now we have to rework that a little bit
i'm gonna move that over
all right so we need a boolean to kind
of show what they did uh so maybe it'd
be better in this case to just have some
sort of struct uh when you go into
combat
uh so
because we could have a bunch of
booleans
for the different things you've done but
i guess mainly we want to say
action done this round
equals true
and then yeah let's have a struct uh
i'll just put it local to this fight
sequence right now
uh byte
options
uh we'll have attack or boolean for well
this might be better as an enum because
we can only really do one thing for now
enum fight options and we can say what
are the options
attack
and inventory
use
i guess that's all we got for now
so maybe we can do something other than
this action taken if we're going to use
an enum now they think about it because
we can have
it default to none
so every time we go into this loop it'll
reset and we'll just go we have byte
options uh and we'll have this called
action taken
and it's just gonna start as fight
options none
so they haven't done anything basically
and while action taken is not equal to
none we'll say
so as long as they've done something or
as long as they're doing nothing we'll
continue this while loop of getting
their action character
and we'll set this up here so if they
press a
we'll set this local action taken
to fight options attack
and we'll use these in a second it'll
make more sense probably in a second
here
and now we need to consider this okay so
combat inventory is going to return
something anytime it's called we're
going to go into that new function so
what we want to do
is we'll go action taken equals
and let's use let's finally use this
ternary operator correctly so we're
going to switch
on this or not switch but operate on
this combat inventory and
if it's true we want to say action taken
equals inventory or actually we want to
return
fight options inventory
else we just want to return none
so this will basically return one or the
other returns true it's going to set
action taken to inventory if it returns
false we're going to say we take no
action
and that way it'll continue through the
loop because basically you know we might
go into the inventory and poke around
decide we're not going to do anything so
we want to make sure we don't use our
turn when that happens basically why is
this underline
unscoped for enum class okay
so we gotta go you know class here
that's why it's complaining all right
options available per turn that's a
really butchered available
cool now i think we're pretty good here
for now
we could have an option to skip turn but
now you got to do something you got at
least attack that's good enough for now
so now we need to go down here
it's basically basically as long as the
monster is alive
we want to do the thing now we gotta
the monster is always gonna attack
basically unless they're stunned or
something but we don't have that logic
worked out
just yet but we need to figure out
uh well this is fine this is all
the monsters attack monster attack
every turn
pretty standard ai for them they just
keep attacking now where's our attack
oh it's right here
okay so
yeah
we have kind of a first strike thing it
looks like because if we hit them they
don't hit us back which yeah it gives us
a little advantage but what we actually
want to do here
we could either do this immediately like
right here
which would actually be fine
yeah this is fine for our particular
logic because
since action taken is going to be attack
it's gonna flip through and well it's
gonna be done with this loop and we'll
go to our next turn basically
and
once we're done with our turn one that's
when the monster hits us
yeah yeah basically monster
it's
when your turn is over
and we already have the logic worked out
in combat inventory to use potions and
switch stuff
and uh yeah we just need to test this
out a little bit so let's go ahead and
hit play
so we're going to enter a few fights do
a few battles and see if we can pick up
some some items
oh apparently we messed up some logic
because we just got swung on over and
over
oh we got our while loop incorrect
basically okay this should be equals
while your action is none continue so it
was just skipping over our loop and the
monster was just beating us down uh yeah
that's not what we wanted to happen all
right no problem there we go back into
it let's go ahead and beat this guy oh
he hurts we got a bow
bows aren't actually usable yet okay
let's defeat this one got a potion of
healing awesome
let's go into our inventory go down use
the potion of healing
and let's exit
i guess we can equip this bow even
though it doesn't actually do anything
because we do melee attacks only right
now which have programmed in range all
right this guy's only got two hit points
oh we got a one-handed sword i'll take
it
all right
uh let's go into our inventory and equip
the sword be done the sword should
enable us to do quite a bit more damage
i don't know if we can beat him though
oh no we can't we won we barely got him
we got a plus two helmet that's actually
really good but i don't think it's gonna
save us uh whip
uh done character sheet let's look at
our character sheet let's just admire
the things are working oh let's see here
oh we only got one hit point left we're
gonna die first thing next fight
unfortunately but we've acquired a
one-handed sword apparently we have
sword spelled wrong we have a bow what's
oh that's d for damage
i i guess i just didn't format there
let's look at character sheet real quick
and check that out
uh yeah it's right here let's put a
couple spaces in there
but dimagge and it'll make a little more
sense
in our sheet there all right but that'll
we'll have to recompile to get all that
i got that plus two helmet which is
super nice but dang i mean we got a lot
of armor
but you know we know the things no
matter what hit for at least one so this
next monster is like guaranteed to kill
us unfortunately uh dang yeah we get we
got four monsters so we're getting a
little better maybe let's just do one
thing let's make one change here and
let's have the user start with a couple
uh healing potions or maybe start with a
couple random items i feel like we need
something we're just getting destroyed
so
let's do that let's go down to our main
after we pick
our class or
yeah we can i guess we can do different
things with different classes for what
you start with
but
yeah for now let's have the warriors
start with two potions i mean he needs
something to keep going because he's
just getting wrecked so let's just go
uh main character
dot us
dot
move can we oh what is it i forget
we have some function here to put stuff
in our backpack right
just forget what it is
oh we have to call the item manager to
do this right so we got to go
item manager actually let's yeah we got
to do this
okay item manager
move to backpack
we need the item which we can call our
random
uh what do we call our random item
generator
drop random item let's just give them a
couple items drop
random item okay that's going to return
two random items based on that whole
system we have set up and the character
is
main character dot us and i believe we
need to make a reference to this
and this is a pointer
right here
and spell the character correctly okay
there we go
so let's actually just do that after we
make our character
right here
let's just do it twice
give the main character a couple random
items uh to start with so let's hit play
take our warrior
go to our inventory okay we got a potion
of healing and a ring nice
now we shouldn't be able to use this
potion right it actually fails because
we have full health so that's awesome
let's uh go ahead and
oh back to inventory go
down equip this ring
okay
done let's go to battle
attack attack attack attack now we're
getting a little low let's hit inventory
and use this potion
cool
and continue attacking we won we got
some boots
sweet let's go ahead and equip these
boots
apparently we have
multiple potions hold on oh it's because
like the potions are sometimes drop as
two it must be a two but we don't i
didn't really program it in to show that
you have two because let's take a look
at it
yeah it's right here we have one or two
so we must have got two there so we
should probably say quantity uh let's
take a look at this inventory again
and now we have in two places so that's
super messy and we'll have to change
things in two places we'll have to
uh adjust things and maybe we'll combine
them somehow but we'll figure that out
here in a little while for now
let's just say if we're displaying
uh this is this is gonna get tough
because names easy everything has a name
but we need to check if it's a potion
to see if it has a quantity or not so i
guess we'll just go
if item
or uh what is this it's item manager
and
there's a check proportion here
is item potion
if it's a potion
oh we need to pass in this item
so if this returns true it's a potion
and in that case uh we need to cast it
to a potion so that we can get the
quantity because as its default item
type
it's not necessarily going to know what
it is
because we can go
get data and then we can go like
quantity except it doesn't know what
quantity is until you passed it so we
got to do that cast
so let's think how did we do this before
it's been a few episodes
let's declare a potion i believe
i think i'm doing this right
set to null to start and then we got a
call item manager i think we have a
function to handle this cast
item two potion and we gotta pass in the
end which is this one and the out is the
potion there and boom
now this what does this do let's look at
this function a bit return to void
out is going to be null
if this fails so that's our check here
we just need to do a null check i guess
since the function doesn't do it for us
if not potion
um
let's see i guess we want to okay we'll
just do if if it's if potion that's
going to be better because i don't want
to have to use break or continue that's
not really going to work here
we'll just get the quantity and so we're
going to say we already have it doing
this with a new line
we don't necessarily want this new line
here
that's fine we'll just put it down below
space it over a few and say quant to t
it's going to look a little hot at first
but we'll get used to it and then we
need to say the actual quantity here so
we'll go potion
quantity
that's going to be an integer i believe
so that should work and then we'll put
another new line okay there we go now it
should work for multiple quantity uh
potions should show us how many we have
so that's nice we still you know we
could put a little notification thing
here for things that are happening like
you gained an item but we've just kind
of skipped over that
so
uh not a big deal let's go to the
inventory we got neck guards and leg
guards i guess we just equipped them
both
and done let's check out our character
sheet all right we're pretty beefy we
got armor we shouldn't take too much
damage that's nice we should be able to
slay some monsters so let's beat up some
monsters and beat up some more monsters
potion of healing nice
go up here and beat up this monster okay
now we're a little beat up but we got
some potions appealing there we go
they're both single quantity uh let's
use one
check out our character sheet we've got
six hit points let's
uh let's equip this breastplate let's
use this other potion check out our
character oh that potion did not do much
we only got eight hit points but we do
have a decent amount of armor i guess we
just go fight and hope for the best a
one-handed sword nice okay swords are
really good because they increase your
damage there's like nothing else that
increases your damage other than swords
so let's go nice we one shot him
he didn't do any damage back and we got
leg guards
we already have lake guards so now we
just have those stuck in our inventory
all right now we've got two pairs of leg
guards
nice got a bow
eventually we'll level up oh this okay
we beat them another breastplate i need
a potion of healing oh gosh this monster
has 16 hp oh we leveled up we got 27
and then we gained some uh
xp from the level up or some hp so we
might actually be able to beat this guy
let's check our inventory nothing
uh-oh we can't seem to exit the
inventory we have a bug uh
oh apparently pressing a did it i need
to look at that that's interesting
okay so i guess you can't just exit the
inventory let's let's try that one more
time and then we'll analyze what the
problem is oh my these monsters are
stronger
okay we've got him though uh oh boy
we're gonna we're gonna lose this next
fight probably so i don't know we might
actually be good okay
d doesn't exit when we're in combat
inventory okay
so let's check that out and we need to
copy this code right here into the
combat inventory too
right here
okay
and let's see what's the problem here d
done equals true
oh this should be an or
or
right
i'm actually a little confused here
must have missed something if you used
your action or you say you're done
yeah that's right
so why you're not done a while on action
it's not you stay in the inventory that
should be right but why was a
functioning to get out of the inventory
that's a little weird so we may have
encountered a bug i guess maybe that's
something to do with this fight sequence
no it shouldn't
oh well
i guess i'm not entirely sure
we'll see what happens
all right but we're done here i guess we
got to press a apparently okay we we
defeated another monster
we're killing it
um
yeah we got all this stuff we keep
getting leg guards over and over we
don't need leg guards
we do need a bow though okay and the
inventory changes order a little bit not
a big deal though oh we're level three
now
we're leveling up so i guess i should
have a way to actually show the level
and our scaling is working
this game is actually starting to
function
uh we got some boots let's equip those
nice okay
yeah it seems to
let's see so what's happening here why
does d not exit
but a does i actually don't understand
because d should be going here done is
true
and it should break out of the loop oh i
know what's happening we're actually out
of the inventory at that point it's just
not
re-showing
this stuff because if you think about it
uh when where you exit the inventory we
are
right here action taken gets changed
uh but we're still stuck in this loop
so we don't get this clear screen update
that's what's happening
so maybe we should have this
right here
yeah that way
it'll display the fight sequence
even after exiting the inventory yeah
that should fix it okay so it was just a
matter of the display it was actually
working right we got a potion of healing
that's really good
and i think we're at the point where we
might want to update something let's use
this potion we kind of need it use
done
character looking pretty good let's show
our level in xp because we can't really
see that
yeah let's go ahead and do that let's uh
go to our character sheet and just say
here
instead of a bunch of dashes
we'll just make like a
an l and then we'll also have
uh xp
and we'll have
next all right so let's format these up
l
space it's going to look a little ugly
for a second just because i'm
working it up here so we need right here
in this area
the level which we can do by you know
one of these functions
basically
get
level
and we can do this again over here okay
so we say level then we say xp
and then we'll say
get
current xp
then we'll say
next
and here we once again
this new line at the end just gonna be a
character
like so
okay so right here we need to say how
much till next level
um i think
i don't know if we have a function to
display that exactly but we do have
get
exp to next level yeah that'll work
we'll display that
all right
so we're on quite a run here we still
haven't lost but it looks like we might
not be long for this world unless we get
lucky uh the
advantages were like hitting really hard
we just got a ring too
our ring one
let's equip that and now our stats are
going to be months drastic we have 16
strengths we're just hitting really hard
so we're like killing these monsters so
fast they're not getting much of a
chance to hit back we may have like
broke the game warriors might be too
strong yeah i just one shot that 10 hit
point guy okay let's go check this guy
he's got 18 hit points let's hit him
once we hit him first seven
okay he's sitting back
yeah let's just keep fighting until we
lose basically we're getting anything
good
no i got a bunch of leg guards but
they're all the same so no point in
equipping different ones oh we finally
were defeated we defeated 18 monsters
see if we can beat that record yeah
chumps
have at it
all right well now it should display
your level and stuff after this next
build because we added that in uh let's
go to character sheet level one zero xp
so everything is actually working quite
good
we still don't have the abilities
in here and we spent most of our time on
the items and uh
in using items say hey look at this we
have multiple potions double quantity i
guess if you get lucky on the potions
you can probably
pretty easily defeat my record
let's not use that let's put those items
sure let's use one potion
reduce the quantity very good
my god am i a master programmer or my
master programmer don't answer that
question but if you do there's only one
answer all right another potion of
healing
look at all these potions we are just
this might be the best run yet
i just want to see the xp thing we're
not really showing the level ups but
here we can see
xp
okay this next is
actually correct so we're getting there
we're gonna ring a leg guards uh let's
equip oh let's use a potion
i guess we can equip this bow although
we don't need it
all right
let's uh go to this next monster to
battle oh god he's going to kill us oh
we barely got him we barely got him we
got to use like all these potions uh
equipped with the league guards now we
already have lake guards don't we yeah
we
seem to get leg guards more than
anything else but it's random so one day
you may other days you may not
uh oh i think we're actually gonna die
we basically i think the randomization
hinges a lot on getting one of those
one-handed swords too you gotta get a
sword and you gotta get potions
appealing we'll just use both of those
killing potions kind of stink they're
not programmed to do very much like two
through five or something we've got some
gloves
but if we keep getting armor we should
get to the point
where
okay we leveled up these monsters
shouldn't be able to hit us very hard so
we were defeated all right we defeated
eight that time but it's you can see
it's it's turning into a bit of a game
looks janky because it's in console but
you know we could always wrap it or add
some graphics later and we could always
update these functions to drop different
items and however we want to do that
chart but you get the gist of it
probably alright so
let's just work on the warriors power
attack because if we go to the warrior
they get power attack we want to see
these abilities
in the list and we got these pretty well
worked out how they work like we got an
ability it scales off of strength it
hits an enemy it's got a cool down
uh so we can look at that whole system
uh let's look at our abilities here yeah
we see it's
whether it gives you a buff or not
whether it affects your hp it's got a
name it's got a cost if there is a cost
it's got a cool down so we'll have to
program that in and target in the scaler
so we should be able to do some some
power attack shenanigans like once every
three rounds we should be able to hit
with a power attack with the warrior but
we get that
at level two so we could even add more
stuff later we could do like uh
else if uh you know get level
maybe we'll give them a level three
thing real quick
so we could just do something like this
it's kind of janky but it'll get the job
done
place back let's give a
the healing surge i think it's kind of a
classic
or i don't know whatever you want to
call i don't know if healing surge is a
good idea uh
trying to think of a better name for it
yeah whatever
healing surge
and we need hp effect
i forget how we had this programmed
exactly because of itself and it has an
hp effect
it heals you i think
if it's enemy and it has an hp effect it
does damage so we just need to change
this ability target to self so let's say
it heals you for four it doesn't buff
you no pointer
uh for now we could we could throw in a
little armor buff or something maybe ah
forget about it cost zero but it has say
a four round cooldown
and ability target is going to be
uh self you owe yourself for four every
four rounds
might be a decent thing to do
ability scaler
uh we'll just say none just a flat
healing
all right so now they'll get another
ability now we just need to display
these in the combat options so this
fight sequence here when we display the
options maybe let's have
an option here to go into abilities so
maybe that'll be b
abilities we gotta call it something
and we'll just also program that in here
case
let's put it near the end after
inventory actually uh case
b
and we'll go action taken equals and
then we'll do the same thing we'll go
uh enter
ability selection
and we'll now have we'll have to add
that here too
uh ability so just kind of doing some
prep work before i make this
uh function here oh
gotta actually copy this there we go
so if they end up using something we're
going to return
that they used an ability if they don't
we're going to just stick it to none and
maybe we'll process that ability right
in this selection so let's go ahead and
make this ability selection
all right fair play i'm out of time uh
this has been a fun episode though i
have highly enjoyed it so we're gonna
have to pick this up uh with this next
section of uh making these abilities in
the next episode so i'm just gonna
comment that out for now and comment out
maybe this little part it's going to
look odd but it should work no it's not
going to work
uh
maybe i'll just do this
i'll just have it ready right down below
for next episode
because yeah we are fresh out of time
here buddies uh i hope you've enjoyed
let's see is it gonna work let's make
sure it actually works uh we can leave
this ability here that's fine
it's not gonna hurt anything let's just
make sure it builds it does
all right
still pretty janky but everything's
working
we do get those two
random items that we start so that's
going to be interesting and if you want
make pull requests add items change the
charts that's all fine with me this is
none of this is set of stone this is all
just you know this implementation here
is whatever but you're welcome to play
around with it so
it is what it is all right let's uh i
guess we don't have any good way of
exiting other than either dying or
closing
all right well i'll see you in the final
episode pretty soon here happy coding
peace out guys
[Music]
you